-Welcome back, everybody. We are
hanging out with Michelle Obama.
Now, Michelle, since
so many people look up to you,
I thought
that you could help settle
some of the biggest and most
important debates of all time.
We did this with President
Obama, and it was a lot of fun.
Are you ready for this?
-I will do my best.
-Let's do it. It is time
for "Michelle Obama Settles It."
-♪ Michelle Obama
settles it ♪
♪ Michelle Obama settles it ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Here we go. Ready?
Is iced coffee
only for the summer?
-Yes. Absolutely.
-Yeah, I kind of -- Yeah.
Yeah. I agree.
-I mean --
-There you go. Next.
Is it wrong to re-gift?
-It is.
-Yeah, I agree.
-You know, it's kind of lazy.
-It is, right? Yeah.
Yeah. I agree.
And if you don't want it,
you can donate it or something,
but don't re-gift it.
-Yeah, yeah, give it away,
but don't -- you know,
literally give it away.
Don't gift it away.
-I totally agree with you.
Is it rude to respond
to a text with "K"?
-It depends on the age. Right?
If you respond to young people
with more than "K,"
then they think
you're mad at them. You know?
If you use words
and punctuations,
I was told, "Mom,
why are you mad at me?
You used a period."
And it's like, "Well,
that's called grammar."
-Alright, a lot of people are
talking about this next one.
Middle part or side part?
-Uh, duh!
-Yeah, of course.
Side part, yeah. I agree.
This one may be controversial.
Best meal --
Breakfast, lunch or dinner?
I think I know your answer.
-Dinner.
-Yeah, of course.
It's dinner. Yeah.
-You think that? Yeah. Yeah.
Breakfast and lunch
are throwaways.
-Right? They're fine.
Lunch is definitely
just all business for me.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Breakfast now and then.
But dinner, you have memories.
You have conversations.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It's bigger.
-You can have wine.
You can have a cocktail.
It's unbelievable.
Oh, yeah, dinner all the way.
I knew it.
Next up, I know
the answer to this.
Pancakes or waffles?
-Waffles!
-You have to, yeah.
You have to, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're right.
Should you wet your toothbrush
before putting toothpaste on it?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah. Yes! You --
You're going to go dry in there?
-Yeah. You know,
you can cut up your gums and --
-It's disrespectful
to your teeth.
-Too harsh. It's too harsh.
-It's too much.
Too much -- Yeah, exactly.
Should you floss
before or after brushing?
-I floss after, because
that's what the dentist does
when you go in for a cleaning.
They always floss last.
So I figure they know something,
so I'm going to do what they do.
-Yeah. I'm trying to think
of what I do.
Yeah, I guess so.
-But have you
been to the dentist?
You been to the dentist lately?
-I love going to the dentist.
-What's wrong with you?
-I love it. I think it's --
I feel great when I leave.
I feel -- Clean teeth.
I love it. I don't need gas --
I'm so good.
I love it.
-Really? That's so cute.
-I love it.
[ Both laugh ]
Next up, oh, next one
is about "The Crown."
Season 1 or Season 3?
-Season 1. Season 1.
That was where it all began.
That's where "The Crown" became
"The Crown," after that season.
-Alright, who gets to pick
the music, driver or passenger?
-Driver, all the way.
You're doing the work.
You get to control
the sound system.
-No.
-You -- No?
-I think passenger, 'cause then
you can get in there there
and you start
looking through things
and you start making
a good deejay set list.
-No, but I want
the driver happy and awake.
-Yeah, I totally --
I take it back, yes.
Alright. Next, corn.
On the cob or off the cob?
-On the cob!
-On the cob -- This is insane.
I'm sorry to even
ask that question.
Of course. No question.
Next, we have,
"Is a wok a pot or a pan?"
-Pan.
-Pan. Yeah.
This is the best question
coming up.
Ready for this? This is
the best question coming up.
Better movie,
"Taxi" or "Fever Pitch"?
-"Taxi."
But I've seen neither.
-What are you talking about?
You -- No, don't you even dare.
What are you -- I was --
-I've been busy! I've been busy!
-It's me and Queen Latifah!
You had to --
-That's why I picked it, "Taxi."
I'm sure I would like that one.
-Oh, my goodness.
You haven't seen either.
Can I tell you a quick story?
-Please.
-I got a --
Ann Curry brought me --
was on Air Force One,
and she brought back
the movie selection card
from Air Force One,
because "Taxi" was on there.
And so I was very excited.
-So you just assume because Ann
Curry had it on Air Force One
that everybody saw it?
-Well, I'm assuming
you were probably there,
and that was
one of your options.
The whole family loves "Taxi."
[ Both laugh ]
I got to get you a DVD.
-That's why it was in the back
where you all would sit.
It wasn't up in our cabin.
-[ Laughs ]
Okay. Here's a good one here.
How do you pronounce the word
at the bottom of my screen?
-"Geero."
-Yes! That is correct!
That -- I just learned that.
I would say "jairo."
-As opposed to "jairo"?
-"Jairo."
-A "jeero"?
That's how my dad said it.
-It's "geero," is right.
-We're gonna get some "jairos."
-It's "geero" --
Yep, I used to say "jairo."
And it -- You're right.
And finally, better way
to end an e-mail,
sincerely or yours truly?
-Ooh.
I usually say "all the best."
But I'd say maybe sincerely
to keep it short.
-You guys heard it here first.
All the best to you.
My thanks to Michelle Obama
for settling
these important debates.
Her show, "Waffles + Mochi,"
streaming now on Netflix.